الكثير من الاباء والامهات يحاولون ان
يقوموا بدورهم تجاه ابنائهم على اكمل وجه
ولكن احيانا يتحول الامر الى هوس
بالمثاليه والكمال ما يسبب لهم الارهاب
فيشير الخبراء اليوم الى ان السعي للكمال
يصبح اكثر خطوره عندما يمارس على الاطفال
من الطبيعه ان يقعوا في الاخطاء باعتبارهم
وسيله للتعلم وبحسب دراسه جديده يعاني ما
بين 25 و30% من المراهقين من الكمال غير
القادر على التكيف اي الذين يسعون الى
الكمال غير الواقعي الى درجه التسبب لهم
في الالم وغالبا ما يتجلى السعي الى
الكمال في صوره الغضب والقلق والاكتئاب
الخوف من الرفض وفي الحالات القسوه السلوك
لانتحاره فما الذي يجعل كماليه شديده
الخطوره وكيف يمكننا حمايه الاطفال
والمراهقين من اثارها الضاره المزيد مع
الكلاب
الاب والام المثاليان يكونان من الشخصيات
الدقيقه جدا يريدان كل شيء جيد وصحيح
بالنسبه لمئات في المئه ويطبقان هذا على
الابن يفرضون عليه ان يتصرف بطريقه التي
يرونها هم مثاليه جدا ولا يتركني له
المساحه ليقول رايه او يعبر عن نفسه هذا
الهوس بالمثاليه والكمال من شانه ان يجعل
الابناء عرضه المخاطر العقليه بحسب خبراء
علم النفس وهم يقصون على انفسهم ويخافون
من الفشل فنظرا لان العديد من الاهداف
التي وضعها الاباء والامهات المثليين
للاطفال غير واقعيه تماما سرعان ما يجد
العديد من الاطفال ان الانجازات والنجاحات
تخلوا تماما من المتعه ويسبب هذا السعيد
كمال ان يكون الاباء مجهودين جدا طوال
الوقت ولا يمكنهم ان يرسموا سعادته على
وجوه ابنائهم كما انهم عاجزين على
الاستمتاع بالحياه بالتالي تكون نتيجه طفل
تعيس غير سليم نفسه
وبحسب الباحثين فان فكره الاباء المثليين
هي اكذوبه كبيره وما يحتاجه الابناء ليس
شخصا خارقا وانما اب او ام جيده ومحبه
وسعيده ايضا ويقول الباحثين ان اكتشاف
الابناء لبعض عيوب الاباء يمنحهم الثقه
للتعلم من ارتكاب الاخطاء ويوفر لهم قدوه
جيده ولهذا على الاهل مشاركه اطفالهم قصص
اخفاقاتهم ويشرح لهم كيف تعلموا من الفشل
على كل حال سال الناس في مصر هل تريد
ابنائك ان يحققوا احلامك ام احلامهم
نتابعه
[موسيقى]
يعني بتمنى لهم الخير وبتمنى لهم ان هم
يكونوا افضل ويكونوا افضل مني
و حياه سعيده
ان انا احس ان هم ماشيين على نفس المنوال
اللي احنا مشينا فيه ان الدنيا ما تبقاش
كل حاجه سهله عشان احنا تعبنا عشان نعمل
اللي احنا وصلنا له يعني
اكثر بس عشان انا طبعا تعبت في حياتي جامد
جدا
لم يتمكن من تحقيق حلمه بيتمنى انه يحققه
في
اولادهم الشخصيه وليمه
من الاب او من الام
[موسيقى]
على كل من القاهره تنضم الينا مدربه
الحياه فاتن سلامه فاتني يسعد صباحك اهلا
بك ما رايك في مجال في الدراسه الى اي
بالفعل الى اي مدى الهواس الخليه
والكماليه يؤثر سلبا على ابنائهم
وكل عام وانتو بخير
سنه ل 30 سنه ومتوسط عمر الزواج في العالم
ما بين الرجال من 30 ل 33 سنه
من 24 ل 27 سنه فيما معناه ان انا اتربى
في الدين واربي في الاخر فبالتالي تطلعي
للمثاليه وتطلعي للكمال في تربيه اولادي
بيكون نفسه
اما ان انا بيكون عندي حلم كما كما يعني
ذكر في الفقير لميس انه انا عندي حلم
فبتطلع ان انا احط لكم في اولادي وده طبعا
غلط لان انا قدراتي ومهاراتي والظروف اللي
حواليا غير ظروف اولادي خالص او ان انا
اتطلع الى همم ان انا بيجيء لي سوشل
افرميشن او تاكيد اجتماعي عايزه اثبت
للمجتمع شيء معين وده ليس له علاقه بهذا
الكلام اللي انا المفارقه معظم القصص
الناجحه وراها دعم كبير للاهل تطوير
الموهبه وتنميتها
نعم دعم وليس هوس في المثاليه نادين دعم
بمعنى تقبلك لابنائك ربنا يخليهم لك يا رب
بكل ما فيهم من صفات او نقاط قوه ونقاط
ضعف وهذا ما اكدته جميع الدراسات على انه
مصطلح الجريت بمعناها المثابره واللي
بيكون بيخلق اطفال وبيخلق اجيال
بتستطيع ان تخلق ما بين الشرف وما بين
الكونسيستنسي او الاستمراريه في الشيء
اللي هم بيعملوه من الاسره يعني انا كم
مثلا همم يعني قدرك تماما ضعف ابنائي في
اللغه العربيه فبالتالي مش هاسيب كل
الاشياء اللي اولادي بيعملوها كويس وابص
بس على نقاط الضعف لان انا لانني مهوسه
بالمثاليه او لانني لدي هذه الرغبه ان
الناس او عائلتي او اصدقائي يقولوا
اولادها حجاب وادريس الفلانيه اولادها
دخلوا الجامعات هذه الجامعات همم
اخر من غير الجراج نوع اخر كانت اشارت
اليه كارايل دويك الاستاذ في علم النفس في
جامعه ستانفورد قالت انه عندنا مشكله
كبيره في التربيه وهي ان احنا بنتعامل مع
ابنائنا من خلال خبراتنا احنا ومن خلال
المخزون اللي عندنا من المواهب او التعليم
او او خبراتي انا كافات مثلا ببصش لابنائي
عاملين ايه وده اللي بيخلف عندهم نوع من
الثابت ولكن علشان اوازن ما بين ان انا
يعني اذهب الى الهواء في المثاليه في
التربيه وان انا اكون اب او ام حقيقي يعني
زي ما انت ما قلت يكون وخلق قصه نجاح من
ابني او بنتي او اساعد وفي تحقيق حلم وهو
وليس حلمي انا انه انا اخلي ابني ده عنده
جلوس 9 يتقبل فشله يعرف ان الفشل ده مش
حاجه همم
يعرف ان في نجاح في النقاط قوه ونقاط ضعف
هي الحياه فقط ليست نقاط قوه
طيب فاتن انت بالنسبه للاباء المهووسين
بالكماليه والمثاليه والذين دائما يرغبون
بابنائهم يكونوا هم الاوائل والناجحين
ماذا تنصحيهم حتى لا يحسوا اولادهم انهم
مضغوطين ام انهم مراقبين او مجهادين مثلا
باحط على نفسي عبء وتوتر وتوصل لتروماس
بتوصل لامراض نفسيه فلازم اتعامل على حدود
تقديم طاقتي دي امكانياتي انا كانقدم
رعايه ثاني حاجه لازم يكون في سمه اتصال
اسال نفسي انا عايز ايه في رحله التربيه
دي وابني او بنتي عايز مني ايه دائما مقاس
هذا السؤال للاباء هل سالتم ابنائكم هل في
حلقه وصل ما بينكم تخصص بتاعه التربيه
ثالث حاجه اسمع هو بيقول ايه لنفسه ان مهم
جدا انت ممكن تكون بتقول له حاجه وهو
بيقول لنفسه حاجه ثانيه خالص تختلف تماما
عن اللي انت بتبص له نعم فتن فيه مقوله في
مقوله بتقول هابي ماما هابي لايف يعني ام
سعيده حياه سعيده هل هذا فقط ما يحتاجوا
ابناءنا
الابناء بنسبه اكثر من 70% لما نيجي نتكلم
معهم بيقولوا احنا مش عايزين اي حاجه غير
ان احنا نشوف اهالينا ما بيزعقوناش علشان
نعمل حاجه طبعا
الفارس عموما او مقدم الرعايه لان في
الفتره الاخيره مش بس الام والاب هم اللي
بيقدموا الرعايه فيه ممكن تكون الجده او
الجده او الاعمام او ما يعني ما الى ذلك
فبالتالي هابي هابي فاميلي هابي لايف
والسعاده مش بس بمجرد ان هم يجتازوا
اختبارات المدرسه مساعدتهم كده في اجتياز
اختبارات الحياه وعشان اساعدهم في اهتزاز
همم اختبارات الحياه لابد من ان من انني
اسقي الشخصيه مش بس دي المعلومات او بال-
بالارقام او بالبريز اللي بيجيبوها لا
الموضوع ابعد من كده بكثير لازم يكون
عندهم سكيلز اللي هتبقى لهم دي الحياه
الصعبه جدا اللي هم
احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر من القاهره مدربه
الحياه فاتن سلامه